let's give everybody some good news
ladies and gentlemen uh Victory you win
I guess Navy removes pride month posts
amid right wing backlash NASCAR Major
League Baseball also targeted so that's
uh that's basically it targeted pride
month is yeah targeted pride month
basically ended in like a day Major
League Baseball had those up only for I
think like a couple hours or something
yeah NASCAR took theirs down the Navy
took it down because they were getting
slammed the funny thing is they're all
like the media CNN is trying to cover
this up they're trying to say like no no
nothing to do with this it was dude they
were always planning on changing their
logos what are you talking about the
meme is that for the month they change
their logos July 1st it's July it's June
5th June 5th they took them all down
yo people are freaking out someone super
chatted us just a moment ago saying they
know somebody in
marketing at Walmart and Walmart's
freaking out because they don't know
what to do so here's the best part we
have this story from CNBC as well it
says boycotts hit stocks hard here's
what might be next for Bud Target and
others caught in the anti-pride backlash
this is CNBC saying their stocks are
going down even right now Target's down
right Anheuser-Busch but oh look at Bud
saw an increase of 0.31 good for them
but they CNN ran an article this is from
June 13 and ran an article saying that
the reason that Target stock is going
down is nothing to do with the
conservative boycotts and it's just
economic factors and Market downturns
except for the fact that Walmart's stock
is stable right around the same time
Walmart lost a few percentage points and
then went back up Target tanked by
nearly 17 points
yeah I don't think that the time is
coincidental but that being said there
is obviously uh you know commercial uh
real estate and the businesses that
function out of there are not doing
great so that makes sense but I think
that the the precipitous decline is a
product of the the protests and I'm
personally really glad that it's
happening I think that it's it's been
far too long that the the left wing of
the political aisle had all of the
populist kind of rebellion against
capitalism and finally the right wing
was like all right like you guys you
like I let me tangent real quickly
because it drives me crazy that every
time there's one of these uh these
divides in our in our society that it
seems as if we're speaking totally
different languages or like the the
opposition doesn't understand us it's
like
no one cared about adults doing any of
this just making it Crystal Clear it's
when you came for the kids that you
crossed the line the average person
doesn't know that though because that's
not how the media is reporting it
because he's reporting it as that
blanket dislike of
lgbts that's that's that's that's
substantially better for the right and
substantially worse for the left or
anybody who views themselves as like
libertarian or classically liberal
because if the narrative is
so many people just don't like the LGBT
stuff
then the average person who's seeing
this is thinking wow no one in this
country is okay with any kind of Pride
oh boy I don't want to get involved in
that stuff and what's happening now is
probably why Walmart's freaking out
because these companies are thinking
what pisses people off is just any kind
of Pride when in actuality it was
specifically targeting kids but they
lied they lied about Dylan Mulvaney they
said it was a single can no it was Dylan
of any promoting Bud Light with multiple
cans of Bud Light drinking them to an
audience was under 21. it's because
they're making products for children
which introduce them to sexual Concepts
exactly the media then comes out and
says conservatives just don't like gay
people and what does that mean it means
that big corporations are going to be
scared to do anything Pride related
which is exactly what we're seeing they
took their logos down the media lied to
try and cover it up and it's backfiring
masterfully in their own faces I mean I
know you guys have made this point in
the past week but it's really important
to understand that these core
corporations do not care about the
lgbtqi plus Community it's not it's all
about their corporate equality index
it's all about their diversity equity
and inclusion scores it's all about
BlackRock it's all about ESG it's all
about the access to Central Banking and
the the political establishment that
wants all of this it's all about 2011
Barack Obama's uh you know executive
order that said that you had to have Dei
departments in every federal government
agency it's all about government
intervention into the economy this is
not an organic thing whatsoever and I'm
sick of pretending that this is just the
the woke takeover of of the economy no
no no this is about the government
and the corporations getting in bed
together and then pretending as if
everybody's gay for some reason the
other thing that's interesting about it
is if you look back at it it's actually
a lot of the people that are that are
gay that aren't necessarily enamored
with the movement call it rainbow
capitalism and don't like it anyways
because they know that it's pandering to
a market that it's disingenuous right
there was a great video from signal
Productions a couple of months ago where
they talk about how woke cap what they
deem is woke capitalism was born out of
the crash of 2008 when all of these
corporations basically the banks all
crashed and they have to be bailed out
and they're like well how can we repair
our image oh I know and then if you see
that great there's this great like side
by side picture and it's like 2000 in
2008 and it's them basically saying no
bailing out the banks and then now it's
like a pride float from JP Morgan in
like 2018 and they just masterfully
covered up what they did by
basically pushing towards an agenda that
they know wasn't for a long time going
to get any pushback from anyone because
nobody wanted to be the bad guy who said
we don't support this we don't want this
and for whatever reason right and now
you see the way this is going and yes it
is ESG scores it's all these things but
to me it's just disingenuous more than
anything it's always just disingenuous
yeah well and and it also It ultimately
doesn't alleviate any of the issues that
these communities are concerned with and
it's just it's a pure misdirect and
that's what drives me crazy and why it
ought to be bipartisan just as it ought
to be bipartisan that the FBI gets
abolished by democrats who are concerned
about Martin Luther Martin Luther King
Jr's either assassination or the
threatens upon upon his life in terms of
the letters where they were telling him
that he should kill himself or from the
right wing where it's like okay yeah you
have the FBI which has been persecuting
and essentially attempting to you know
soft coo Donald Trump since 2015 him as
a Trader exactly and or covering up for
Hunter Biden's laptop or you know the
list goes on and on it's like these
ought to be by part issues the left otta
also hate ESG this isn't doing anything
that you want to see in the world
ultimately it is creating the very
monopolies that you claim to be fighting
yeah they're creating them they love
Disney even though they hate
corporations it's it's really funny
there's a great amount of kind of
cognitive dissonance with a lot of it
they they don't understand that a lot of
these corporations that they claim to
hate but then they love other ones so it
doesn't actually make any sense I think
it's a symptom of the self-indulgence
culture right like they can't see past
the fact that they may be part of that
group or they don't want to seem like
the hateful person they can't see the
other implications of why this business
is happening because if they don't buy
the pride merch if they don't
participate then they themselves are a
bad person there's no long-term thinking
really and that's what I find most
interesting I think you know we all can
recognize that especially gay marriage
with one of the fastest shifting
cultural issues uh of anything I don't
think anything compares to the way that
especially Our Generation younger
Generations just got on board we're like
yep everyone should be able to get
married sounds good uh this was not true
for the transgender movement and I think
that is what is uh the splintering point
here instead of it becoming like a more
embracive embracing uh open-minded
Community they started pushing things
that people felt uncomfortable with and
were willing to speak out about I don't
think they realize that that uh adult
consenting adults acting and behaving
and getting married was completely
different from uh gender ideology that
has to be introduced before puberty
there's a lot of authoritarian Notions
and all that like we it's we're not that
long off of bake the cake that wasn't
that long ago that was what 2016. yeah I
mean it's ongoing yeah but the original
case was 2016 gay marriage was legalized
when in 2010 was it 2012 2013 I thought
so yeah like there's a lot of
authoritarians in uh 2014 I thought okay
so so that's not that long off that
right so a lot of those like they were
persecuted for a period of time at least
in the older Generations right the older
generation uh of people in that group
were persecuted amongst other people and
I do think that there is a lot of fear
out of the like what is James Lindsey
point out because it's the Specter of
the dad not accepting the the gay son
right there's a lot of fear there but
that's not the reality in a lot of
places that we live in anymore like my
generation was not raised to think that
way we still don't think that way but
the problem is there's no Nuance there
anymore let's also clarify the
government is never going to make your
dead accept you no that's not how it
works and I think that that's a big
problem with these folks is that like
because they've dealt with a culture
that was very antagonistic towards their
lifestyle they have turned towards the
government and kind of replaced their
father in that in that way and it's it's
extraordinarily unhealthy and I'm not
speaking broadly here there are
obviously lots of gay and trans people
that don't feel that way but I do think
that that is a big reason that the left
kind of has replaced both God as well as
their father uh with the state family in
general 2015. okay okay wow Mary always
gets that one right she always says 2015
like that doesn't sound right to me but
apparently it was 2015. yeah I thought
it was earlier yeah so did I but that's
uh like that's the thing right they've
been like they don't they recruit very
well because they push out family they
push out the concept of any type of
religion and if you don't or sorry no
sorry one one specific type of religion
they're they're much more tolerant of
the of the other religions depending on
when they're talking about it and who
they're talking about it with but in
this case there's a there's a big push
away from family in those cases because
they want you to be reliant on the
government and they want you to see the
government as your family as your
parents those are all prerequisites for
joining a cult what you just described
is what you do when you're trying to
groom someone into a cult is you offer
them basically one way one way out you
you alienate them from their friends and
their family make them fear the outside
and make them fear the outside exactly
yeah I I mean I think with uh the
expansion of the lgbtq plus all of the
letters Community they really did miss
the point of what was happening in
culture right they just thought I mean
it's very sort of greedy of them to be
like we'll just continue to include more
things and more people feel marginalized
and then run to us and feel a part of it
I just wrote this story today uh the
alliance defending Freedom uh was
representing a dad who's a Middle School
soccer coach in Vermont and his daughter
was a freshman in high school a
biological male who identifies as female
another teenager was allowed to change
in the locker room with all the girls
she told her friends like that feels
uncomfortable he's a dude he shouldn't
be in here she got reported to the
school she got suspended she had to take
part in an equity Circle or strong
session it was crazy her dad who's a
coach in the school district defended
her on Facebook and he got uh suspended
without pay until and then so that
happened uh end of last year he just got
a settlement for like 125 000 he they
have to take down all of the uh gender
related stuff in the school off its
website I mean we can see that there is
a a different current happening with
this end of the alphabet they have
talked on to this original group I think
we didn't see this with you know issues
like gay marriage because number one it
affected adults predominantly and it
didn't have to be introduced in schools
to children I think this is where you
know if you're trying to promote ESG you
should have been able to see this train
wreck coming because there these things
are not the same even though you put all
of the letters together yeah well I
think this that kind of stems more back
into the progressivist ideology where
like you just never you're never content
and and you always go faster and you
always want to go after the youth
because they're the most malleable and
that and that's where the line was drawn
by the parents it's like you cannot come
for our kids we will stop you and a lot
of people felt that like look when we
legalized gay marriage that was the last
great civil rights battle right right
what do we now we need a new victim
class yeah we need more people to be up
for us and uh and I just like it's it's
also I think a big part of this is like
there's plenty of good people who just
don't understand that this is going on
that this type of war is going on within
that Community I was looking at a meme
earlier today from a friend of mine
who's a good person is absolutely a
fantastic person and the meme says it's
a picture of a rainbow and it says like
boycott the sky they're turning the sky
gay what they're doing like this is a
person who doesn't understand the
nuances of the argument right they don't
understand that I don't care if you and
adult are gay and do whatever you want I
don't care I care that you're pushing an
ideology on children who cannot consent
to that type of sexualization and so so
the way I explain it there's this video
that's going around where it shows a
bunch of school children waving Pride
flags and marching in the school and the
reason why I explain uh there's a tweet
from Tim Heidecker where he said you
know Screw you Matt Walsh the goal is to
normalize this for kids okay and so I
try to explain listen
that's grooming all right literally what
the school is doing is grooming they may
be unwitting accomplices to The Grooming
process but they are and there's it's
one thing to show a child the rainbow
and say Rainbows are in the sky and
they're pretty that's not grooming it's
another thing to say here's a rainbow
with the intent of explaining to you
adult sexuality
so grooming what the these people try to
like I gotta say Tim Heidecker really
does Jump Right In to what the purpose
of grooming is 100 the purpose of
grooming is so that you can introduce
one step at a time from the lightest
introduction to the hard most hardcore
elements slowly over time it's not
grooming if you were to walk up to a
person and say let me explain to you gay
sex and these things in this book that's
not grooming that's overt that's you
going and saying I want to show you this
thing so if you were going to uh uh
introduce these Concepts to a child
innocently oh it's just Pride Love Is
Love that's the first step in what well
what does the L stand for what does the
B and the G stand for these are adult
sexual preferences children don't need
to learn about these things until after
they learn about the general birds and
the bees so why is that children who are
under that age are being introduced to
this type of these types of ideas and
more importantly
there's a video of a pride parade in
West Hollywood where there there are two
adult men performing sex acts on each
other mainly one guy and another guy
it's BD set BDSM Kink foreplay not like
anything super gratuitous but it is a
sex act a foreplay BDSM in front of the
public on a a truck in the parade
spanking him with with flogging him and
you know his his bare ass in front of
everybody including children yeah that's
grooming but that's level two level one
is look at the rainbow isn't the rainbow
pretty the rainbow's great you should
come to a pride event and see how
awesome it is then when they go to the
pride event what do they see they see
foreplay in BDSM that is why it is
grooming so if they're now showing the
stuff in the front of a Target store
Pride flags and all that stuff no
they're not saying Love Is Love they're
saying the next phase in The Grooming
process is to introduce children to to
what they're doing on the streets and
then where do you go from there you get
kids doing drag where there ripping
their clothing off on stage in gay bars
for money which has already happened so
then you get someone like Tim Heidecker
who I assume is probably just a very
ignorant cultist he doesn't know any of
this he hasn't ever read any about it
anything about it all he knows is that
he's on Twitter and everyone around him
says it's totally fine it's totally
normal accept it so then he just says
yeah yeah and starts tweeting about it
or it's possible he actually is super
down with grooming kids because he's
into kids or something like that but
like let me just say it once again once
again simply you show a child a rainbow
and say Rainbows are pretty not grooming
you show a child a rainbow and say do
you know what love is do you know what
pride is do you know what lesbian means
yeah that's that's grooming that's what
they're doing and those conversations
should be had when the parent is ready
with their child and I think that the
the big problem is that many
progressives and essentially the entire
Democratic party as well as some on the
Republican side too think that public
schools are there to raise your kid and
that is not the purpose it is to educate
them on the Bare Bones of how to be uh
you know to become an adult and be a
functioning person in the world it's not
to teach them about sex it's not to
teach them about who you know sexual
orientation or any of this other stuff
and and the fact that they would do it
surreptitiously is such a just backstab
to the parents and the fact that the and
then to have the FBI investigate these
parents is just unspeakably evil is
modeling bad
no of course not
what kind of model lifestyle so you show
up and you wear like a a frilly sundress
and you make cookies and they take
pictures of you and then they sell in a
catalog cookware lifestyle modeling no
big deal you're wearing a suit and
you're you've got a briefcase you're
smiling modeling is totally great we've
all heard the stories about young women
who will be approached online by someone
or see an ad that says come be a model
and then fly out or a modeling agency
you know how it works here's what we've
worked with and then what do the women
end up actually doing because they know
that if they tell the woman we want you
to be a prostitute on camera they'll say
no you have to groom them by saying
modeling is a totally normal thing that
everyone knows and loves now hold on if
a modeling agent goes to a mother who
has a small child and says
I think your kid should model I rep I
work with this agency we do a whole
bunch of different products is that
grooming no of course not kids model all
the time but what if the person's
intention is to expose that child to
something sexual now you understand
grooming and that's what they're doing
at these products and that's what
Epstein was doing as well well and I
think that's a great example I would
also point out that a lot of parents are
already aware that people who are likely
to groom your children are people who
have regular access to them so it might
be someone that you're working with in a
professional capacity but it it could be
their coach it could be anyone at their
school it could be a babysitter you
leave them with like that's why parents
have to be so Vigilant I can understand
the fear right but
just because the school says oh we're an
authority and we're kid is supposed to
know this like if you as a parent feel
like hey I don't think they're old
enough to be talking about sexual
orientation I don't think this
conversation about gender is
age-appropriate like that's why we need
more parents to get involved in school
boards because you guys know what's best
for your children and I think that's
where so many parents feel like they're
trusting the experts I'm not a teacher I
don't know anything well you're doing
your kid and you should speak up and a
lot of the teachers the worst of the
worst of the ones that say you should
trust us we're the authority and you've
seen those posts before and that's just
you should just let the teachers teach
there are probably lots of wonderful
teachers right it's not every single one
there should be cameras in every single
school and some I'm sure are decent
people right for the parents yeah
this is one of the big problems that
came with online schooling that teachers
got upset because parents were like wait
what are you teaching that wasn't a
problem that was great problems for the
teachers for the schools because they're
having school in their living room and
they're suddenly much more engaged with
what their kid is is hearing and what
they're being told uh I just find this
to be the most obvious solution right
imagine it's going being a parent and
overhearing as you're making breakfast
the teachers say don't tell your parents
do you know what gay means well when a
man loves another man he takes his pants
off don't tell your parents I told you
this and you're like you're like the dad
of the mommy there I'm going like what
the you walk and you're like what
is this
and that was happening to a lot of
people that's the biggest silver lining
of the lockdowns was so many of the
parents sitting at home realizing
exactly what kind of indoctrination
process their child was being put
through and and finally putting their
foot down I mean on top of the fact that
they were being Force masked and then
ultimately forced the medication upon
them it's like they you just realize
that you're entrusting a bunch of
untrustworthy people to raise to rear
your child strangers you don't actually
not exist about untrustworthy but just
strangers right and like we took a lot
of parents took for granted for a long
time that you just assumed that like I
like I'm thinking back to my education I
don't know if my parents ran any
background checks on any school I went
to they just figured you know you went
to this public school and and that's
what you did I went to public school in
a really small town and at least four of
my friend's parents worked at the school
and we knew them but again I went to a
very very very small school it's unusual
if you live in a major suburb and you
have more than 200 kids in each grade
there's no way you also know their
teachers person no I had a thousand yeah
exactly my graduating class was a
thousand people it's like it's basically
a college campus at that point but
you're dealing with a bunch of uh look I
I don't really I'm just I'm just so
grateful that so many people I mean if
you look at the charts of homeschooling
over the past 30 years it's unbelievable
it's like parabolic it's fantastic and I
think that you know we talk a lot about
the cultural degradation in America so
much of that will be alleviated and and
solved by homeschooling and and
essentially cutting that tie between the
child and the state in terms of thinking
like this is the person who's going who
I'm going to rely on not just for my
education but for my food my employment
my uh you know the language I'm supposed
to use like all of that it gets
brought back down to the basics and you
get to have people that are are form
formulating you know real autonomous
independent you know kind of Americans
and it's not like we have great test
scores coming out of America right now
anyways we're not exactly the whole
system it's not something to brag about
it's not knocking out of the park where
you're like yeah it's risky but at least
he's getting a great education that's
not the story yeah thanks for watching
this clip from the timcast IRL podcast
hang out with us live Monday through
Friday at 8 pm and become a member over
at timcast.com for uncensored members
only shows exclusive thanks for hanging
out and we'll see you all next time